welcome to CBS this morning I'm Gayle
King with Tony Duke opal and Anthony
Mason wherever you are I hope you're
drinking lots of water because more than
half of the country will be hit by a
dangerous and record-breaking heat wave
over the next 24 hours this is very
serious and it will last through the
weekend that's not good
nearly 150 million people from Arizona
to New England are under heat alerts and
by the weekend cities in at least 14
states are expected to break their high
temperature records era Barnett reports
from the heart of the heatwave he's in
st. Louis it's sweltering
I'm on shirt number three today across
the country millions of people are
trudging through the first major heat
wave of the year in New York City
officials opened dozens of cooling
centers to the public take this heat
situation seriously take precautions
particularly when it comes to folks with
any kind of vulnerability in Madison
Wisconsin volunteers are doing just that
knocking on doors checking on the
elderly here in st. Louis kids are
cooling off on public fountain filled
playgrounds yesterday temperatures hit
95 degrees here and they are expected to
rise but the rest of the week high temps
could hit the upper 90s and could feel
as high as 110 degrees there many
dangers of being exposed to excessive
heat both in the short term and in the
long term Michael why session is a
professor of geophysics at Washington
University in st. Louis he says people
are at constant risk of dehydration
exhaustion and heatstroke those most in
danger adults over 65 and kids under 4
just this week a 10 month old girl died
after she was left in a hot car in
Richmond Virginia the best thing to do
during a heatwave is stay out of the Sun
when possible stay hydrated stay in cool
areas try to avoid leaving pets or kids
in cars these are places where often
fatalities can exist now this is serious
roughly 660 people die from heat related
illnesses each year and get this when
temperatures outside are above 92
Riis temperatures inside a vehicle can
become fatal for kids within just 10
minutes in the CDC urges everyone who
has to be outside today in these heat
zones to limit your sun exposure as much
as possible during mid-day hours Anthony
yeah it's very serious Errol thanks